[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
son impactantes las imágenes que dejan
las protestas en colombia organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos
corroboraron el uso de artillería por
parte de la fuerza pública para contener
a los manifestantes mientras eeuu los
países que integran la unión europea y
la onu expresaron su preocupación al
presidente y bando
y es que más de una semana de protestas
no tienen en jaque el mandatario
colombiano convocó al diálogo pero hay
sectores de la población que no se
sienten representados el reclamo que
inició en contra de la reforma
tributaria que ya fue retirada derivó en
un clamor contra el uso excesivo de la
fuerza policial y por políticas que
eliminen la desigualdad social y
mientras tanto en méxico hay indignación
por el desplome de un paso elevado del
metro de la capital al menos 25 personas
murieron en el accidente cuyas causas
son investigadas por una empresa noruega
y vamos de inmediato a colombia para
tratar de entender qué está pasando
debemos recapitular a mediados de abril
el gobierno de iván duque presentó al
congreso su proyecto de reforma
tributaria con la que pretendía recaudar
alrededor de 6 mil millones de dólares
para hacer frente al déficit fiscal y
ayudar a la golpeada economía colombiana
a combatir los estragos causados por la
pandemia del cofidis y drive la reforma
que les explicamos a fondo en la emisión
anterior de aquí américa y que pueden
volver a ver en nuestra página web era
ampliamente impopular esto debido a que
para recaudar el dinero arremetía
principalmente contra los ingresos
medios y bajos en una evidente
desconexión con la realidad que viven
las poblaciones más necesitadas del país
para el 28 de abril varios sectores
convocaron a un gran paro nacional y los
ciudadanos salieron masivamente a las
calles día tras día obligando al
presidente duque a retirar la reforma
para el 2 de mayo
pero las protestas siguieron
principalmente de manera pacífica
ahora para exigir el retiro de otro
polémico proyecto de ley el de reforma
al sistema de salud y para pedir el fin
del uso excesivo de la fuerza policial
para contener las manifestaciones al
margen se registraron hechos de
violencia el 4 de mayo varias estaciones
de policía fueron vandalizadas el caso
más dramático fue en bogotá donde fue
incendiado un comando de atención
inmediata con policías dentro mientras
que el abuso de la fuerza fue registrado
en vídeo y corroborado por
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos la onu y la unión
europea manifestaron su preocupación
mientras que algunos congresistas en
eeuu incluso pidieron el fin de la
colaboración económica con el país
suramericano argumentando que los
contribuyentes estadounidenses no
quieren que su dinero se ha utilizado
para prácticas represivas recordemos que
la unión americana ha proveído durante
años entrenamiento al ejército
colombiano para luchar contra grupos
armados ilegales
eso precisamente es lo que despierta la
preocupación de human rigths watch y
amnistía internacional entre otras
organizaciones que reclaman que las
fuerzas armadas colombianas están
entrenadas para combatir terroristas no
ciudadanos
imágenes que parecen de una guerra y no
de una protesta
los ciudadanos han dejado en evidencia
el uso excesivo de la fuerza por parte
de la policía
[Aplausos]
y organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos como human rights watch
y amnistía internacionales corroboraron
el uso de armamento militar para
recuperar el control de las ciudades
hemos corroborado el uso de tanquetas
con lanzadores de proyectiles múltiples
dirigidos a manifestantes es un arma
peligrosa e indiscriminada el ministerio
de defensa debe dar explicaciones
en colombia la policía nacional depende
del ministerio de defensa y no del
interior entre 2017 y 2019 la policía
cometió 289 homicidios casi el mismo
número que el ejército la ong temblores
registró casi 40 mil casos de violencia
física 1100 cada mes y 102 casos de
violencia sexual casi tres casos al mes
durante la primera semana de
manifestaciones en colombia el escuadrón
antidisturbios hoy llamado es más está
en el punto de mira de las acusaciones
de muertes en las protestas y no es la
primera vez este escuadrón creado en
1999 de manera temporal se estableció
como unidad policial con formación
antisubversiva y desde su creación hasta
2019 se le atribuyen 43 ejecuciones
extrajudiciales en septiembre de 2020 un
hombre que rompía las reglas del
confinamiento perdió la vida a manos de
la policía un hecho que desató protestas
masivas y que terminaron con 13 muertes
más por parte de los uniformados
mientras que en el paro nacional de
noviembre de 2010
él es madre disparó un proyectil contra
el joven dylan cruz y lo mató un evento
que conmocionó al país un país que
todavía no sabía que en el siguiente
paro nacional las muertes se contarían
por decenas
para hacer frente a la crisis sin
precedentes el presidente iván duque
instauró un diálogo con varios sectores
como antesala de las elecciones de 2022
que condicionan las posturas de sectores
políticos pero en el contexto de este
caos salen a relucir las manifestaciones
pacíficas como este baile frente a la
plaza de bolívar en el corazón de la
capital colombiana frente al esmad la
policía antidisturbios
[Música]
me acompaña piscis a quien acabamos de
ver bailando en este vídeo del 28 de
abril
piscis es activista y bailarina
cuéntanos entre los reclamos de las
manifestaciones están precisamente los
derechos de la comunidad lgbt que tienen
representación en este diálogo convocado
por el presidente y cuéntanos cuáles son
los principales problemas que tiene la
comunidad en colombia
hola cómo estás buena tarde el primero
que nada agradecerte por el espacio pues
mira la verdad que como tal una
representación para la comunidad del g20
no no existe porque nosotros somos una
comunidad en la cual sigue viviendo en
las sombras invisibilizada marginada y
dentro de las principales problemáticas
que tenemos justamente es ese no que no
contamos con leyes que nos respalden no
contamos con el apoyo del gobierno ni
siquiera para para nuestro sector y eso
provoca que haya mucho mucho desempleo
que haya muchas pocas oportunidades de
tener una vida digna en nuestra ciudad
bogotá se han venido presentando muchos
asesinatos y crímenes a mujeres trans
justamente por por toda esta
desinformación que hay y también el
inclusive la policía y el sector de
salud no no ayudan ni atienden a las
personas el eje el eje vete wyplosz
entonces es una situación bien fuerte y
dramática en la cual todo lo que está
pasando en el país nos afecta muchísimo
por
que imagínate tú todos los filtros que
ya tenemos y aparte de eso ser una
comunidad tan tan vulnerada y tan
violenta da día a día la verdad que es
es muy difícil es muy difícil vivir en
un país como colombia tan tan machista y
tan
tan tan que tan ni siquiera sé cómo
explicarlo porque te puedes dar cuenta
en esas medidas que tomaron inclusive
del pico y cédula medidas que incitan a
la homofobia la transfobia que
provocaron miles y miles de abusos para
las personas el eje el eje el eje
bueno y si ustedes eligieron esta forma
de protesta que es pacífica el baile
boat cuenta de más de qué se trata esta
es de esta forma de expresión que
ustedes me realizaron durante la primera
jornada del paro nacional
ok bueno el bug es la expresión
artística dancística en este caso de la
cultura ballroom la cultura ballroom es
una cultura maravillosa que tiene
décadas existiendo nace new york'
específicamente en harlem se desenvuelve
desde los años 30 pero su boom fuertes
entre los finales de los 60 70 y 80
y bueno esta cultura es un espacio
seguro para la comunidad lgtb blog's
verdad dentro desde las miles de
expresiones artísticas que tiene esta
cultura ballroom encontramos el bou que
que es la dancística y decidimos usarlo
por múltiples razones la primera y más
importante es porque como personas el
eje el eje wyplosz pues nuestras
imágenes no son mostradas en sociedad no
son representadas y bueno justamente el
bou es este esta danza que nace de la
resistencia de la disidencia de cuerpos
que buscan expresarse y hacerse visibles
también pues para nosotros fue muy
importante usar este típico específico
de bou que es un estilo muy particular
dentro de los tres que existen elegimos
el buffet que es un estilo que
justamente viene de las mujeres trans no
de esa época pioneras en este estilo que
donde se muestra un empoderamiento desde
la energía femenina desde la feminidad
algo un tema que sigue siendo tabú y
bueno en nuestro país colombia ese es un
tema muy muy taguao en el tema de la
feminidad no entonces quisimos usarlo
quisimos llevarlo también a la marcha y
quisimos estar también puedes
visibilizar a nuestra cultura y
comunidad ballroom de aquí de colombia
que crece día a día
piscis muchas gracias por acompañarnos
en aquí américa y por visibilizar esta
forma de expresión artística
y me despido con la imagen de la semana
al menos 25 personas perdieron la vida
en el desplome de un paso elevado del
metro de la ciudad de mexico los
servicios de emergencia trabajaron
durante varios días para buscar víctimas
bajo los escombros mientras que el
presidente llamó a una investigación
transparente sobre el colapso de los
vagones de la línea 12 una línea con
historial de problemas
[Música]
con mariachis los familiares de los
fallecidos en el colapso del metro de la
ciudad de mexico les dieron el último
adiós
la indignación se ha apoderado de los
mexicanos después de uno de los
accidentes de metro más mortíferos en
décadas en la capital mexicana bueno
este es un homicidio calificado no se le
puede decir de otra forma
mucha tristeza en mis propios vecinos
mira nunca me imaginé que aquí en la
ciudad de méxico iba a pasar es este
tipo de
accidente
da mucha tristeza por los que por lo que
murieron y por los que están en el
hospital y las autoridades dicen que no
pasa nada
nada para ellos las investigaciones
preliminares sugieren que una falla en
las vigas de soporte horizontales causó
el accidente la alcaldesa de la ciudad
de méxico claudia jean mount pidió
evitar especulaciones y prometió una
investigación exhaustiva esto debido a
que las críticas se ciernen sobre el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador y
su canciller marcelo ebrad quien era el
jefe de gobierno de la capital mexicana
durante la construcción de la línea 12
no vamos a escatimar nunca jamás
el recurso que se requiera para
operación y mantenimiento esta falsa
idea que ha estado diciendo a alguien de
que es por un asunto de austeridad no
tiene absolutamente nada que ver en la
hostería republicana para nosotros lo
que significa es la disminución de la
erradicación de los gastos suntuarios
del gobierno suntuarios pero no ha
habido una reducción en la operación y
mantenimiento de las distintas áreas del
gobierno incluido el metro de la ciudad
de mexico
el accidente ha planteado preguntas
sobre la seguridad en uno de los
sistemas de metro más concurridos del
mundo que transportan millones de
personas a diario a través de la
expansión urbana de la capital los
ciudadanos denuncian que esa línea
presenta múltiples defectos y que podría
producirse otro accidente similar
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí a américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en las redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho y sigan viendo france24
[Música]